anyways I'm hopefully hopefully my
internet is fixed now so I don't have
any more problems anyway
hello good evening good morning good
afternoon wherever you are there in the
world and welcome to Sidetrack your
Sci-Fi TV and movie channel
how you doing house thanks for joining
me doing pretty well that's a World Cup
feeling all right for uh
this town going up and uh going up in an
array real quick
that's what we're going to be talking
about because it looks like I mean we
can't say the strike is on because we've
still got a vote in the morning but
let's be honest
the strikes on I mean it's it's I agree
virtually certain
yeah I was with some sag members
yesterday one of which who has kind of
uh uh they sprang their leg the other
day so they have a little limp leg and
uh he's still getting ready to go on the
picket line so they're preparing
well I'll just run the intro and then
we'll crack on and get into it
[Music]
hey Shelly's in town Shirley right well
first of all I gotta say
this hasn't happened before as far as
I'm aware that the actors and writers
have both been on strike at the same
time 43 years 43 years it was a year it
was the 60s last time it happened
bad Hollywood is already pretty much at
a standstill yeah I mean that's that's
fair a lot of Productions are already
shut down oh yeah living out here it
feels like it
yeah so I mean
is great in it from in one respect
it gives the writers more ammunition now
all of a sudden
you know could this story a couple of
days gone deadline about they're willing
to let the strike go on till Autumn
until basically
wait for the writers to come in and say
well I can't pay my bills and come back
cap in hand sort of thing yeah and
that's what they were really willing to
do
um Michelle has just made exactly that
point
um and if that's harder with actors on
strike as well
because you can't do anything
um
the other thing is I mean that they were
hoping to get some sort of Deal or at
least allow actors to do some jobs even
that didn't happen so
we're actually looking at things like
Comic Cons and stuff or personal
appearances voiceovers is one of the
things apparently they were going to try
to do for like they could still do
adverts and things and allow the actors
just to do bits and Bobs like that but
it didn't happen
so I'm sorry like no is this so it's
okay
but so I mean we really are at a point
of like dear God what the hell
I mean yeah
so we have got some stuff about Stargate
I have spoken to one guy that works
um very close to all this sort of thing
um I can say that he does work at an
agency and one of the larger talent
agencies and he's given me his opinion
on all of this and what it means to
Stargate et cetera Etc but let's let's
have a chat about the strike first
because actually the
um
the sagafra the the deadline story today
I think is very interesting so
when we come down and we start obviously
this this is talking about everything
that's happened that they've got to have
a vote in the morning
um and then we have sort of some of the
statements so Fran Drescher
um the uh skills negotiating good faith
and was eager to reach a deal with
sufficient address Performance needs but
the Studio's response to the Union's
most important proposals have been
insulted and disrespectful of our
massive contributions to this industry
the companies have refused to
meaningfully engage on some topics and
others completely strong holders until
they do negotiate in good faith we
cannot begin to reach a deal we have no
choice but to move forward in unity and
on behalf of our membership with a
strike recommendation to our national
board the board will discuss the issue
this morning and will make its decision
so again saying
we're going to strike in the morning
basically yeah essentially okay
what do you think about
to just the way that that statement is
or what you're saying I mean it's strong
words
um I well I got a couple thoughts about
it honestly uh my first thought is a
it's a good thing she came out saying
this because you know the day before the
strike she decided to fly to Italy and
go to a party that yes she had booked
for months and months and months but
taking selfies with Kim Kardashian while
the rest of your industry that involves
a 150 000 members is about to go on
strike it's not the best uh for Optics
and stuff like that of course no
um so that that's that's kind of my
first thought I'm glad she said
something that that was at least
strong-worded for her own people uh in
that message but at the same time it's a
it's interesting it it it it it it kind
of implies a lot going forward and
well this is stonewalling basically says
to me that there are certain aspects
they were trying to negotiate in the
studios who've refused to even engage
with them about it and I'm thinking AI
uh what then Stone morning is it certain
Financial aspects
it's okay so the the little bit of
information I have from the people that
I know that are in these guilds uh I I
was doing a play Yesterday producing it
so I got to talk to some of my friends
that are in Sag and some that are in the
wga and sag and uh Netflix is apparently
mostly the residual base they just don't
want to have they're they like their
data encrypted they don't want to
actually have to share their their data
much less residual because if they're
not willing to share data they're not
probably going to pay you for the lack
of of the data they're even sharing and
everybody else is AI is what I've heard
so it's it's Netflix for just data in
general they don't want to share
anything and then all the other Studios
they want to AI they they they don't
necessarily want to replace but that's
of course what everybody's saying around
town uh it feels like they want to
replace everybody I guess and I think a
lot of people I've spoken to it's not
even that they're scared about today
it's of course they're scared about five
years ten years exactly appreciation's
got to cover the next at least five
years yeah they're just saying they want
to do four or five years I think the
contracts last something like that
but then that's what they're worried
about they want these things to be done
now
um because they don't have this argument
again in a couple of years when it's
maybe too late and they're arguing that
actually some work jobs might not have
been lost to AI but some work is being
diverted away from a human because AI
can do it quicker
um I argue that this is an age-old
argument that people argue like this
when cars were invented and computers
were invented and everything yeah
but I do also see the point that this
technology is a little bit different
and can be used in ways that maybe
previous technology couldn't and it's
already been used like that I mean
mostly by like YouTubers that have taken
the time to like make Tom Cruise in this
scene or make Keanu Reeves in this scene
or whatever but yeah it's yeah if a
YouTuber can do that and all they need
is two three weeks of putting in this
person's face and from this scene this
scene this promo this interview whatever
if all they need is that I mean we could
be deep fakes in a month you know which
is kind of interesting it's got to be
yeah there's there's an element of you
we need there should be an assumption
that you own your own like image rights
but there just isn't in lots of ways
anybody can do that and there's no legal
repercussion and and that's just
ridiculous but let's see what the um so
the studios basically released as a
statement just after we're deeply
disappointed that the studio Actors
Guild has decided to walk away from
negotiations this is the Union's choice
not ours damn those unions in doing so
it has dismissed our offer of historic
pain and residual increases
substantially higher caps and pensions
and health contributions audition
protections short and serious option
periods a groundbreaking AI proposal
that protects actors digital likeness
and more rather than continue to
negotiate the studio Actors Guild has
put us on a course that will deepen the
financial hardship of the thousands who
depend on this industry for their
livelihoods that to me is a call to
everybody that's not an actor to say Bad
actors bad
you're like your job now your money your
financing now being
put it harm we've tried they won't
listen
that that is one big that's
so political and everything it said
there to me what do you think
oh yeah no no it's the definition of
politics right there it's it's just
it's kind of beating around the bush
without beating around the bush it's
very straightforward but also not you
know it's it's this is what we've tried
to do but it's not working uh we want it
to happen still nonetheless and now it's
your job to do it instead of us since
they they're not negotiating with us
anymore so I guess they've tried to
throw the ball in our court
as the populace as as the people
they're trying to shift public attention
public opinion again for writers and the
actors that's what they're trying to do
and that's that's very obvious yes so do
as the public do we tend to side with
one or the other or do we just try to
stay objective and stay back and let
them kind of figure out themselves of
course Twitter and now threads and
people like that uh or people on those
sites are going to be talking crazy and
and uh hammering both sides into the
ground of course but um
but I've had a long day at work so I am
enjoying a beverage so sorry about 9 30.
with this news I might catch up early
yeah yeah I've um I've been at work
today I've been on duty and it's always
a nightmare but I've been thinking about
this all day but I'm trying to get
people to talk to me about it so
tequila flavored beard Yum Yum Yum
anyways steal anything
so I mean this really is it's crippled
Hollywood
one of the things
um I'd like to say I spoke to a chap
earlier and he was saying that one of
the things they've got concerns about
um it's not just it's not just that when
the strike ends people think well they
could just go to work on a Monday
morning and crack straight back on
it doesn't work like that they said a
lot of these Productions may take
weeks to get restarted
um they they don't know what sort of
states the sets will be they may need to
touch up and things they don't know
where people will be everyone has to
sort of come back to people are going
home
um but you just said look you've got to
do things like get the food trucks back
and things it's just there's a lot of
things that need to be done to get back
it can take months oh yeah I'm filming
abroad somewhere
and remembering this is if this isn't
just like actors in America this is any
actor that has worked in American as a
member of this
um Union
so this is actually shut down projects
everywhere
you know it's not just it's not just
Hollywood that shutdown it's really lots
of things I mean like Bollywood and
stuff would be fine they're not bothered
even the BBC has to do certain things
because certain actors have gone I've
got on strike
so but um this isn't if this was
resolved next week this is going to
cause massive problems this will put
them back months at least yeah no like
you just said not only do they have to
just figure out the whole
re-handling of a set rebuilding of a set
or or just reconstruction of what they
might have torn down in a brief period
but they have to not only bring in new
fruit food trucks and and do the
contracts for those do that per who's
going to be here per day because there's
different levels of food trucks and
things like that for different actors on
Set uh not even thinking about all the
different contracts you have to get for
the actor to get back on set because the
second everything's back everyone wants
to get going so who's going to get going
first whose contract is going to keep
them from being able to go to this
project whose contract's going to keep
them from going to this project it's not
it's just not not feasible for it just
to go back just immediately and uh it's
gonna take take a while especially with
how slow things have gotten if it's come
to this much of the standstill
to get that momentum and go on again to
get the ball rolling is going to take
something it's going to take a big push
because I think the thing isn't a lot of
the sets will just be left they're on
sound stages and things if you're if
you're filming on location then that's a
problem because you've got to you've got
to re-book the location you've got to
get any permits you need they all need
to be done again so that can take a
little while but are you saying that
even sets because the sets aren't like
they're not concrete they're not Stone
you know they're not stealing they're
made out of basically plywood I'm saying
if you leave them for a couple of months
they fall apart oh yeah Plywood And
styrofoam just painted to look pretty
yeah they need almost constant
maintenance so unless somebody's
actually going in and doing that
maintenance which they should have made
it because I mean the guys that do that
sort of thing oh they're not on strike
so if the studio will interactively pay
um but the ghost sent to me but they
don't because they just shut the thing
down everyone goes home
everyone
so and if you're on a short-term
contract for a deal that contract is
just it's just ended
so I mean it does take a lot to get
these things restarted again I'm like I
didn't even he was listing off honestly
he went for about 10 minutes just listen
off all the different things and like
the food trucks was the the one thing it
just sort of said you have no idea how
hard it is to get things like food
trucks
to to get things like this because they
don't that there are certain companies
that do it that send these things to
Studios but if they aren't busy they
want to be busy every day so they're
sent off to other places they're sent
off to whatever so because they never
want to be sat doing nothing
to bring them around too think about it
how many if they have 500 if it's a
cattle cough or set and there's 500
extras and there's
30 40 main cast and then another 80 Main
crew that crew in the uh the crew in the
main cast might eat another set of food
trucks but then you got to feed the
cattle crew you got to feed the cattle
call that 500 group of actors 300 group
of actors sometimes 800 000 actors
that's a lot of food that these people
have to plan to bring in and then it's
there's a lot of planning and a lot of
putting together that happens and
I think I think the point of that is
that there's a million things we
wouldn't think about that need to be
done yeah
um but at this time hundreds of
thousands of dollars per day on a set
and just those little tiny things that
you just don't think about
but um I I don't understand that this so
this argument with the deadline saying
that they're willing to wait right now I
understand that a lot of Studios they're
struggling at the moment they don't have
the revenue they did they're still very
wealthy don't don't let me argue I'm not
gonna argue that I'm not arguing that
these guys are on the breadline they're
not
but um excuse me they're not doing as
well as they were some studios are
actually in genuine trouble I spoke to a
chap who works in finance a week ago he
works in Hollywood in finance and he
said basically Paramount we've got maybe
12 months and then they're in trouble
the main reason being they owe a lot of
money uh it's about 15 billion at the
moment
um they don't have the revenue stream
they can manage the current debt but the
problem is interest rates are going up
and a lot of those loans need to be
refinanced this time next year and it
says if interest rates are still high
Paramount might be in real trouble
and that could be one of the oldest
studios in history
could be going around the pan you know
one of the old big three or big four
yeah so I mean they could go the way MGM
MGM nobody thought MGM 20 years 30 years
ago would become what it did and
actually basically go bankrupt yeah but
it did it had to sell everything a
Paramount could be the next MGM
um and that's a that's a big problem I
mean even Disney Disney have got
obviously enough other things that they
will always be able to finance their
debt but they owe a lot of money
um well uh just just while we're
thinking about like sag after just
striking and stuff something that I
didn't truly think about which just
makes perfect sense is
the parks for Disney they hire Union
people all of those people are union
actors a lot of the times
it's not necessarily stag they hire sag
actors but they hire uh there's like
Avion or something like that there's a
couple different other unions that are
all like ancillary unions essentially
and they all coincide with one another
they're all striking as well so that's
kind of what happened last time I think
for Iger to be kind of that big man to
be like all right guys let's let's make
a deal you know I I can't afford yeah
if it's an industry-wide strike again
yeah
the the parks are gonna be the big thing
right there I think now some of the
studios I could understand that they
might go you know what we've just been
through covid we had two years of that
crap and we can't afford this but
actually the streaming services did very
well thank you very much because we're
off in the house and all we did was
watch Netflix
we're now going through a um cost of
living crisis and people are turning off
some of those services but they had very
good two years
I don't see how the studios think well
this seems to me like a game of chicken
basically who's going to go gint first
and and they think the writers are but
this is hurting the bottom line because
only stuff that is actually in the can
is going to be new on our screen so the
next six months
um editors and things can still be
working but if you can it ain't coming
we're going to have a lot of reality TV
very shortly and a lot of reruns very
shortly
you know and Netflix and stuff they just
won't have anything new for a bit
they'll bring in all they'll bring more
old stuff on like they do anyway yeah or
they're going to bring in a lot of
foreign content
yeah so I mean which I I am just
horribly dyslexic so I can't really read
a lot of North Korean TV
um so um yeah if South Koreans are North
Korean would be great
what are you watching Pyongyang I'm
watching a bit of North Korean
television and now I feel I need to um
fight against the bureaucracy of my own
controls or whatever I don't know
I've been brainwashed
um
I want to go get shoes with big heels
and um because that's the way it wears
anyway
um
so I I this war of attrition though that
the studio seems to be going into is it
because they're willing to take a
short-term hit
for long-term gain the thinking being
they have to give as little money to
these people as humanly possible because
we can't afford it
or is it literally just more greed
basically understand that they just they
just think we've got so much money we
come out we can outweigh you [__] go
on do what you want to do we can
outweigh you
yes
but also I think the degreed aspect is
we think it's God I want to be hired by
the wga one day I have to preface this
every freaking time but this is not a
good time for a strike and I feel like
the the God okay yeah don't I might be
screwing myself over in the future a
little bit here but nobody watches this
channel don't worry about it oh but they
might that's the thing but
I feel like the writers are
are not necessarily just as greedy but
asking for more pay at this moment is is
being greedy and as beings too uh self
grandiose self-assured because these
studios are falling apart they're all
falling apart and for this industry that
already pays better than just about
every other industry I don't know if
it's the in the writer's best interest
to be pay us more and and stuff like
that same thing with the actors and and
yes most of this is for the working
actors the working writers who do not
get paid like most people get paid uh
but that's that's the thing we don't
need to be asking for more pay we need
consistent pay that's the biggest
difference I think is where the greed
really comes in and where Hollywood
feels and looks and seems out of touch
is
give us more money give us more money
hey California is broke as hell
nothing's working in this state first of
all and then you come into the City and
stuff and and you see this happening
everything's at a standstill it just
kind of feels dystopian in a lot of ways
and and I I feel like it's it's greed on
both ends both ends of the table both
sides and they're different types of
greed of course because the studios are
like hey well we don't want to pay you
that much obviously but if they would be
willing to pay consistently it'd be a
whole different I guess uh scenario and
we'd be talking about it differently
instead of oh they're pitting one
another against each other and all that
it'd be a conversation and a compromise
much more so I guess but
it's it's screwy in saying that I'm not
against the writers I think the studio
needs to do
I feel for the writers like I don't
think this is the right time because of
the global recession it's just it's a
hard time to be asking for money for
more money but we do want to nip it in
the butt where in five or ten years we
don't know what jobs are going to be
like we don't know what the landscape of
anything is going to be like with AI and
if people can deep fake you right now
they're going to be able to deep fake
you a lot of Hell a hell of a lot easier
in five years uh even easier in 10 years
so it would be nice to go ahead and nip
that in the butt and have it where
actors can continue to hone their craft
yeah I think that's the focal point or
should be the Deep fake right is it that
I mean I think video of deep fake you
can sort of tell
so you know you can still tell it's not
it's not quite right
um but I mean stills of deep fake for a
couple of years now have been completely
indistinguishable and remember this
isn't like big evil corporations deep
faking people this is idiots at home
with a laptop this is people as smart as
Matt with computers just doing stuff I
don't think masculine of course but it's
just people that are that intelligent
with computers that are capable it could
be yeah whatever a video appears of me
doing anything embarrassing Matt did it
or I was drunk
chances are I probably thought it was
funny
um but um uh yeah all of my stories
start with either I was drunk and this
happened or I thought this was so funny
at the time and this happened
um
some of them and they're just like
nice one Dad thanks what murders you
streaked round where naked it was so
funny at the time
that was strong uh anyway
um
so
I did speak to this guy today again as I
said that that works one of the larger
talent agencies
and I just sort of said well look what's
this going to do for Stargate and
another project start there's a couple
of Star Wars projects there's um a
couple of other things
loads of sci-fi there's a couple of
moves that we're supposed to start
filming
um I've been really excited about the
He-man live action movie and it looks
like that's dead I'm dying no you He-Man
is the greatest hero of Our Generation
and they needed a live-action movie damn
it
so no that was terrible all right you
need a good live action movie
um I needed to take the bitter taste of
my of the Kevin Smith cartoon out of my
mouth yeah that's why I made that huh I
kind of noise it's like I love Kevin
Smith but that just wasn't I couldn't I
couldn't I still watched it twice but it
wasn't good that wasn't good
um I could see what he was trying to do
with it he was trying to do something
that felt like the original but it was
just yeah
um so
I was I don't know I was talking to him
about this and everything like so why
where does this put us with a lot of
these
um problems and he's he said this it's
the wild west name it says they've never
known anything quite like this
um they thought this was sorted two
weeks ago yeah and I didn't think I even
reported it on the channel That A lot of
people they thought this was sorted
um or they thought they were it was
about to they thought there was a big
breakthrough so they were like right
let's get let's get going and let's get
a few things up and running let's stop
making some money again and then after
two or three days they realized
okay well I mean it was still pushing
people were still pushing a lot like we
just got I think one of the things that
people haven't realized is you know that
uh that that the deadline article with
the the I don't remember which
producer or big head of whatever company
said that last uh uh statement that we
read through but I think like we were
saying Iger wants to kind of nip this in
the button a lot of ways like he did
last time or he's about to and and
people with parks are Universal and
Comcast will kind of be in that same
boat but
yeah
uh
oh God I brain fart real quick that's
what I was thinking Deadpool and
Wolverine just releasing those
um costumes on on this online in the
past week was a good way to get Studios
kind of in people's good graces again
and now that sag-aftra is
striking there's no Deadpool on set
right now that's that's done so
everything's shut down yeah
I mean like the dad knew Daredevil
series I'm excited let's tell about that
but it's been shut down for three or
four months now they shut it down early
on because it was being picketed at the
literally at the gate
um so I mean you know I was I'm so
excited about that and now instead of uh
early next year it's gonna be the end of
next year yeah
at the earliest yeah assuming this is
all resolved reasonably quickly so
um so anyway I was asking him instead of
Dr so so what is their opinion like I
said he works with quite a large talent
agency
um
what what are they doing what are they
playing what's their thinking and he
basically said they're assuming now that
any project
regardless of stage of development
is at risk
so they are basically planning for
anything to get canceled there is no
assumptions that anything even if it's
filming will be allowed to restart the
longer the strike goes on the more
likely it will be that it'll just be
more cost effective to shut stuff down
and start something maybe potentially
start something new or at the end of the
day the longer things go on
the more costs cut in more savings the
studios are going to want to do on the
other end of it and they will blame the
strikes they've already been blaming the
strikes for loads of projects getting
canceled the writer strikes now they've
got two strikes they complain
um what what do you think about first
because we're including Stargate in that
oh yeah sadly yes
um
I mean yeah it's it's it's
happening it's going to happen I guess
and we just gotta hope that it's the
shortest amount of time possible and I
don't know how to I mean they even had
Federal mediators come in there so I
don't know how exactly
this timeline can be pushed forward from
just the public perspective or even from
someone that lives in this crazy town
um I don't I I think it's just too high
up I I don't know if we really have the
the wherewithal to to push anything
forward I guess as sad as that is you
know usually you're all right well push
a stock price down here or you know
someone will say boycott this or
something and like two percent of a
stock price goes down in a company it's
like all right let's do this or
something like that I don't think
anything like that's going to work this
time around we we just have to kind of
wait it out and I know that kind of
sucks to say as an answer but
it's kind of the point we're at yeah
Alexander he made the point that um well
he sort of said look consider this a
clean slate now whatever we thought was
true before
it may or may not be true when this all
when this all ends but the one thing he
did say was you don't want Executives
having time to think
because it's the last thing you ever
want to do and he actually says we
actively
um so so when a new project starts we
get people in quickly and it says there
is an active
um thing on their part that they want to
do things as quickly as humanly possible
before any time anybody has time to go
or may announce second thoughts and this
is the ultimate second thoughts yeah
um they are going to basically
potentially have months
looking over every project they've got
thinking about it to certainly just
dwell
yeah uh secular one because I said what
head of these businesses how do these
Strokes affect other businesses the
thing is going to remember Hollywood's
industry a big chunk of the industry
around and All America and I said this
is going to affect the West as well
because if you've got any project if
it's filming in America but you've got
an American actor in it because you want
an American actor because that would
sell in America better
that act is going on
so there are projects so this is
completely screwing I also believe that
any actors that are members of the Union
because they've worked in America
I think they have to get like dispensed
they have to like get like a thing to be
allowed to continue working even if
they're not working in America so like a
British actor could be a member of this
Union and technically post a strike even
if they're working over here
and they have to sort of like write a
letter and like ask
uh which is just ridiculous yeah and
don't quote me on it but I think if
you're a member you have to like at
least show that like you're you're with
everybody once at some point you either
have to go like on one of the organized
strike days and go and actually strike
or you have to send them in a letter or
do big old social media post or
something like that uh not positive but
yeah
basically Dave yeah the the strike is
kind of worldwide in any any actor that
works in America needs to be a member of
The Guild
so technically I'm sorry but um at the
end of the day like foreign actors who
have become a member of The Guild so
they can work in America though it's not
quite the same but I think it's more
like if they want to be able to work in
America in the future they need to
actually really seriously consider about
what they do
um and if they don't strike then they
could have their membership sort of
revoked and then they won't go to work
in America so
um it's complicated it's not it's not a
clear-cut area yes or no
the one thing then okay so we thought
and we've said lodestones Stargate so
we'll focus on Stargate because that's
what we actually care about let's be
honest
um we care about all these other things
as well but we do careful
like you know the big round circle right
here there's a reason why this is a
circle
of course
um
we thought we might get an announcement
to San Diego Comic-Con where would you
put the possibility of that now
um
in in the the negatives and possibly
yeah
if if I had to uh give it a
give it up something I'd give it like a
eight percent chance I don't even know
if I can give it a double digit chance
I'm gonna give it an eight percent just
because that sounds like a decent number
I guess like my understanding is
you can't the actors can't even do
appearances like that because they tried
to get they tried to negotiate something
so they could
um and it failed right
um I would argue as well that this this
strike effects
act as any actor right and 95 of these
actors maybe not that high but a good
percent of these actors we've never
heard of right oh yeah
it's everyone and they haven't got
millions of pounds in the bank to be
honest it's our facilities they're on to
walk up and down that I think he with a
banner going strike strike strike
because she's got millions of quid in
the bank Vin Diesel can shout as much as
he likes he's not going skint anytime
soon
a lot of actors are actually live month
to month you know they and they're going
to be in trouble very quickly
uh yeah so I mean that's a real thing
that like I said it's the actors you've
never heard of that are going to
struggle with this
um
and they're the ones that are going to
be hopefully shouting the loudest in a
month or two because I mean it's
completely selfishly I just wanted to
get back to work
um you know they want to get back to
work too everybody kind of wants to get
back to work it's that's that's the
thing it's I guess finding to do it
which is fine yeah okay
um no I think that no we need a good
deal and it is worth a bit of short-term
pain that is me being just completely
selfish you know um David has sent us a
Super Chat which is very kind of you sir
always great Contents I press the daily
work you put in to keep starting it's
hyped up
yeah we do we try
um even if we get yelled that
occasionally
um but then we'll move away from that um
but no thank you so much Dave I just
really appreciate it um
so yeah
Stargate San Diego Comic-Con we've been
saying for ages they were in two minds
before the actors striked about whether
they would
um do that right whether they were going
to announce it sounding a Comic-Con
and the question for you even if they
did
no actors will be on the stage
if we're right I have heard conflicting
things about this I have heard them
actually act some actors are allowed to
do personal appearances but then there's
this story two days ago about how they
were trying to negotiate to allow actors
to do it so I'm not 100 certain actors
aren't allowed to do personal
appearances but I don't think they are
if they're not sag members then they may
be able to of course uh
which which Stargate doesn't hire like
huge huge people all the time which they
I mean they do a good chunk of the time
which which those people are definitely
sag members but
I there could be some Stargate folk that
aren't zag uh I I'm not positive but
that would probably be the only way that
might happen I think but any of your
Heavy Hitters are are sag members I
think film in Canada
fill it with Canadian Actors and pretend
they're American
I think I do that
um
oh you could get some good actors
British actors you can do that yes we'd
all be the villain everybody would be a
villain everyone or an egghead geek that
would be everybody would be an okay
uh because that's all British people
ever play
um but but yeah I mean
no seriously I I don't think there's any
chance of this because like I say they
would have nothing the other thing is
what would they even announce
we're going to do it great when
wow
no one can write a script
and even if they can no one can appear
on it and that's the thing even if they
I mean because they could still be
working on the script you know just
completely unofficially at this point
but if they go on stage and say we have
a script and then anybody asks when did
you do that and then they say oh well
during this strike maybe they're gonna
get some bad press just from that uh
just from some timeline purposes the
only way of course I'm just just this is
not going to happen so do not clip this
and go oh my God this is gonna happen
you know just one second captain
was my favorite cartoon when I was a kid
I [__] loved it
and I cannot unfortunately turn off the
heat
uh I was in Texas two weeks ago and damn
it's hot it's like it's like 105 degrees
on like your cool days
did you take off all your clothes I am
again
we can talk about that on here you gets
have air conditioning we have nothing so
when it gets out here we die
I mean British people are like we can't
when's the rain coming back we can't do
this it's like you're on an island go
for a swim yeah no we can't do that have
you seen the state of our water
um industrialized
um but yeah
um it's yeah we we had a heatwave a
couple of weeks gone it was very
unpleasant and we've had rain for like a
couple of weeks and we're like yeah this
is this British Summer's back and then
it's supposed to go hot again next week
we're like oh God damn it
it's just gonna be humid at that point
um
[Music]
but um but yeah I I like I said this guy
that I was talking to is basically
saying that before like this Clean Slate
blah blah but
they can't announce it San Diego
Comic-Con
the only thing they could do is if they
have Brad Wright pop out there and be
like we're doing this or Mark Fergus and
uh Hawkeyes we hop out there and be like
we're doing this or whoever nobody would
care if Brian if they got product right
on Gatos would go freaking crazy for one
it'd be like Brad's back baby but we
know that Brad isn't involved
um if they put Mark Mark Ferguson or
ghost up there that would be exciting
yeah there's no there's no except so I
mean the only point of doing it San
Diego Comic-Con is to build excitement
and to make a spectacle out of it
they can't do it
well I mean well that
all hypothetical of course this isn't
even hypothetical we just kind of gave
the hypotheticals but we talked about a
little bit before the stream uh hopped
on it's true
okay uh track and con is that gonna be
out awesome that's only the first few
there's a few other there's quite a few
there's five or six star actors assuming
at this point though that the strike's
done by them or they won't be
that's a good point yeah I mean then
you've cut a lot of the the baby San
Diego Comic Con is dead because the
assumption is that well that we know the
strikes aren't gonna be done by then
it's next week
um but other cons have started to try to
book people in but actually this news if
this goes on a month even those cons are
going to start going oh crap yep I mean
maybe two months out they're safe but
anything closer to that there's there's
just
start start planning a a new plan
because you're gonna have to replan
everything not not rework a plan it's
it's replanting a whole new plan at this
point I mean Sunday Comic-Con is going
to be just a dollar's dishwater I mean
it's just gonna be
one of the things they're actually doing
um is that they're doing a Babylon 5
panel and J michaelinski is going and
there was going to be a couple of the
actors but I'm thinking now JMS is going
to be stood up there on his own
um is he part of the writer's Guild is
he even allowed to do that
parents right so I think he can do that
writers presenters directors they can
still present because they're not an
actor I mean so acting or appearing in
that way or doing an interview isn't I
think this is where I think I'm not 100
certain actors aren't allowed to appear
at Comic-Con but if they're not well for
one if they are allowed to be a common
cone why aren't they
that San Diego there aren't many that
have lined up at the moment
um no one big no one's like that I would
consider like active is actually on the
list
um
but also I mean I don't think they can
but writers and stuff they can because
they're not
an actor yeah
so it's my understanding so
um
so yeah JMS might be up there on his own
to promote his new movie
um and almost like
it's a bit crap at that point you just
kind of want to postpone the panel
yeah I would yeah but he's got the DVD
coming out he's got it oh damn
so the DVD comes out literally uh it's a
start of all at the start of August I
think
uh so they've kind of got to do it at
that point you can't even actors phone
in or anything at that point there's
nothing like that there's no zooming in
or
yeah and I know a couple of people that
are trying to set things up for
Comic-Con and they're saying like it's
all going to be sort of like they're
trying to just sort of like interactive
stuff
and it's sort of like you know it's like
it's not gonna be the same it's not
gonna be the same
um but part of me is okay with that just
not not for the film aspect because you
know I love film and that's like the
thing I'd be going to Comic Con and
that's why that's really the main reason
I go to Comic Con is all the film stuff
but yeah
is this going to allow it to go back I
think we mentioned it a while back is
this going to actually allow to be a
Comic Con again where maybe we can have
a movie con or something next year like
like the comics supposed to be a little
bit Yeah because it is not a a Comic Con
anymore it's a comic character or oh
maybe this is a big enough franchise to
start doing comics about kind of Khan
versus an actual Comic-Con
my understanding is and I'm not homes
uncertain on this so please don't quote
me because I've heard conflicting even
people in the industry are not 100
certain which is why they have to send
out loads of advice just before when
like the strict the strike will happen
basically the first thing that happens
is they'll send loads of advice to all
their members you can do this you can't
do that and we'll have a bit of priority
I think but I like as I said if they
were allowed
they'll well we'll know next week
because things like um Tom Cruise will
have to stop doing interviews and stuff
for
um Mission Impossible and any other
films that come out there just won't be
any
um but
um I would have thought though I would
argue I'm not acting so I can surely ask
why can't I do it I'm not acting
but you're promoting acting work I don't
know I don't I don't really know why
they're not allowed to do it but if
they're not I think it's like an Optics
thing it's just part of their their
personal brand coincides so much with
the brand of the uh the film that
they're in or the TV show that they're
in at that time that
I I guess it it can be conceived in a
way as at least writing contractually
like oh yeah you can't do this because
you just doing this would push
up against whatever I guess the the
strike saying or or whatever the studio
wants you to do or or whatever
Etc
etc etc 30 degrees enough which is about
80 degrees Fahrenheit 86 sorry nearly 90
um is not perfect
uh it's death weather and we we push 40
37 degrees in this in this state um last
year and we've never had heat like that
ever in this country we're not built for
it no you're built for it you're you're
texting you can accept it I built the
rain
all of my clothes are rain related
clothes
oh I mean well yeah we're super rainy
but we're just swampy so we just accept
the rain we don't really use umbrellas
too much or just kind of normally win
I'm not built for that I'm like I'm just
pairs of shorts out there you know the
weather gets warm I'm like I mean
there's a shorts oh my God I don't even
know it's been two years since I've gone
out
um you go hop in it but I don't know if
you want to hop in your rivers and swim
in those like I don't know how that
works out there
any actor that isn't a member of the
scream Actors Guild can work can do
whatever they want the problem is the
Screen Actors Guild
is pretty much necessary to do a lot of
work in America so everybody's a member
pretty much the screen acts as good your
production is either
a sag production or it is not a sag
production there's no in between I mean
and you can hire
sag actors to work non-sag jobs but they
have to go through loops and hurdles and
have to like sign weird contracts to be
able to do so and then vice versa you
can have non-sag actors work on sag jobs
and that's that's pretty straightforward
and easy but after three days on a sag
job if you're getting paid sag level you
get sag vouchers and I'm one one voucher
away from being uh eligible to be a sag
member and uh at that point
you become a a must join
cheers uh but yeah you become a must
joined and and you don't necessarily
have to go pay that three thousand
thirty three hundred dollar entrance fee
to become a member uh of the Union but
you're encouraged to at that point and
every everything you work in uh it tries
to not necessarily force you to do it
but there if your hand could be forced
they would be forcing your hand
essentially because they want you to be
a sag actor they want more people in the
union and
most most film TV actual legitimate like
projects with narrative tend to be sag
there are very few that are not uh short
films student projects things like that
even those can be stagged a lot of times
they're not but those can even be sagged
the the non-sag things tend to be
commercials and even with like giant
companies those are a lot of the times
still sad commercials because they're
hiring sag actors Sam Jackson's not
going on Capital One and saying whatever
uh I forgot the little jingle or
whatever they say have it your way or
whatever
um
that's not it but whatever the the
Capital One jingle is uh what is it
money in your egg that's gonna piss me
off uh it's I don't know I've got
Capital One here oh I'm a Capital One
member I should know it it's
like put money back in your wallet or
something like that I don't know it's
obviously a lot more catchy than that
but he can't go on there and do those
commercials right now it's none of these
people that are
contractually obligated to commercials
the ATT girl can't go on and do a bunch
of uh ATT commercials right now and Flow
from Progressive she's not going to do a
bunch of commercials right now they're
sag members so they can't
uh maybe if the if Jamie from uh the
progressive commercials uh her flows
little second in command if that if that
guy's not a sag member he could kind of
take over for the next couple like
episodes or whatever they count their
commercials as but yeah if they're sag
do they have Progressive over there
no
we'll come to the USA
what is that a bank
program is insurance
no we don't have that are we a
Prudential checkout
oh yeah I can act I can do sad
I can do Angry we usually I beat you you
got to take over for the the American
Jamie
um I can do confused
actually those those are the two that he
tends to be confused and upbeat he's
just kind of happy range of emotions
I've got um
um but yeah the world secular monk did
just say this uh yes and no
it can't be a large scale zag Stage
production
but it can be smaller scale uh and then
even that's iffy because it if it's like
uh currently the play that I'm producing
is a Hollywood Fringe Festival play
there's like an Edinburgh Fringe
Festival there's a whole bunch of French
festivals across the globe and they're
great for smaller kind of plays but if
you're a uh a play
um
oh come on the the words troop like a
troop uh that's not what I'm thinking
but essentially a troop if you're part
of a a play uh concerto a troop of
people that are doing stuff all the time
then it's likelihood of some of your
higher-ups or just castmates or people
that are in the troop ending up being
sad members and making that a sag set
are pretty high so those aren't even
able to do things so it has to be like
truly independent small level theater
Productions and that's like
still iffy but that's like it it's that
or non-union work on commercials and if
you're a union member you cannot do
non-union work on commercials so it's
iffy because the commercials are iffy in
that aspect of things as well they're
they're actually trying to negotiate a
little while ago to allow indie films
and things to carry on
um and just to get stuff go because the
argument was basically that these
Productions I make so little money and
they have such little but if we if they
shut them down they'll just die they'll
just they just won't come back they
can't afford to so try not to kill them
that wasn't even agreed
so
I mean I would actually argue there's
going to be a lot of stuff that is like
creative and you know I love to because
a lot a lot of the really creative stuff
is the stuff that makes no money at all
oh yeah it loses money
um horrendously you know and all that
stuff is gonna really struggle it really
is because it's a double here all of
these Productions have just gone over
covid
when they were basically told to go home
for two years
they get over that we just start getting
to a place where we're getting going
again and they're all being told they've
got to go on strike
um
it's only but the bonus is only stuff
that's not sag is going to be out it's
going to be going so you could go and
get a a brilliant part in some play at
the moment just because the theater shut
so I'll go put something on
so you've got a big problem and then I
could go in and do my confused that's
thoughtful damn it that's thoughtful
well that's even like the harder part
about it is maybe I couldn't because if
I do that that means I'm not showing
solidarity with sag or that means I
wouldn't be showing solidarity with
whoever which means once I am eligible
why would they take me at that point at
that point you're almost blacklisted a
lot of times
um obviously I'm a little fish so
hopefully they don't do that but like
they'll they'll Blacklist any name
because you know nowadays it's just it's
it's you type a name in and it's there
so
everybody I'm not sure that surely a lot
of the acts the performers that do like
stuff at Disney and stuff a lot of them
are just kids
in costumes
they're not gonna be members of sack
they're not
gonna talk and you know
kids running around in Mickey Mouse
heads though couldn't they No Yeah by
kids it's like 18 to 25 like that's like
I'm 45 years old if you're less than 30
of course yeah but it's kids in the
sense where they're they're legally able
to do whatever the hell they want with
them uh like and it sounded bad but
I don't think uh everyone's union
members that works at the park uh at any
of the parks but yeah
most of them are I think if there aren't
like um a princess or something that's
open actually doing speaking and
actually needs to like they do their
prey didn't they and I could see they're
just pretty people and they just say
hello to the kids and they're just
dressed up and they're not going to be
like actors and actresses but I know
some people do this as careers I mean
that's not just totally Europe is you
know it's just a bunch of it's their
part-time job something
um
ancillary unions those are those
ancillary Union ones
but I would just get the janitor dressed
up in a Mickey Mouse and I just just
don't just don't hit anyone
go and do the thing and just go and run
around but don't hit anyone and just
think nobody will know the difference
um
but they would though I guess because
it's just college kids
um because I I one of my friends she she
uh she was on season two Euphoria with
me she uh she she what's it called
what's the what's the little it's not
the jungle cruise boat but it's like the
the the
oh it's it's it's like the miniature
cruise line that goes through like the
Little River around there she's the the
captain for that so she's
does all that kind of stuff and
it's it's intense uh she she has to be a
member of a couple different things I
guess but like it's not intense in like
your typical intensive like this is hard
hard work but it is hard work and like
Disney's anal about everything like yeah
yeah
they've literally someone drew uh
someone wanted to put Mickey Mouse on
their kids Tombstone their kid died at
like eight ten years old or something
and they wanted to put Mickey Mouse on
their Tombstone and Disney sued them
like kids
they did put Mickey Mouse on the
tombstone and that's why they do I'm
gonna force them to remove it so the
parents are like Are you seriously going
to make me remove my child's my dead
babies Tombstone and Disney went yes yep
you bastards so that's same company
running that and that's that's why a lot
of that and I think that's why those
career people that tend to work for
Disney tend to join unions because oh we
could be screwed over at literally any
second any second of any day and and
they're like Disney's just anal about
everything they do they want it to be
perfect they don't want you to uh do
something that might look bad for the
company so they have so many like strict
little standards that you have to adhere
to and and like like it was it was
getting really hot out here of course
it's not that hot because we don't have
humidity out on the west coast but when
I go back to the swamp I I get reminded
very quickly
um but out here this is what 90 95
degrees and people are like oh my God it
was so hot it's not too bad for me but
generally out here people think it's
pretty damn hot but they're not allowed
to take their jackets off unless it's 90
degrees I think outside so you have to
be wearing a full Blazer unless it's
above 90 degrees
which is BS because you're already
sweating like a pig at that point and
and you know you're usually wearing like
a white kind of fluffy shirt under so
you're just sweating through that shirt
after you take a blazer off and that's
for guys and girls so that's interesting
because hello children yes I know I
stink
how are you lollipop no no no from
lollipop thank you in trouble but um
yeah
actually I'd be unconscious perfectly
dressed unconscious on the phone it's
only 28 degrees get up it's too hot for
me I'm British
um uh Laura said this a minute ago it's
it doesn't
necessarily coincide with all this uh
but
I I you know I think Bob chapek gets a
bad rap I think
Iger might be the reason Disney's in a
lot of the the the the bad stuff they're
in right now and
jpeg is the biggest scapegoat possible
for them because he was there for two
years he was there to change some stuff
up but all of this stuff was already
being changed by Iger prior to him and
he just kind of furthered iger's agenda
and now iger's back and of course he
gets two more years which makes sense
because you want that stock price to go
back up and if you keep changing heads
and Studios your stock price is not
going to continue to go up people will
be like there's there's no consistency
uh over here and there's really not and
I think that that there's more idea than
anybody else don't kill me Disney but
like
I I I I I I think the biggest problem
with with agar is he he's an amazing
businessman but he really doesn't give a
[__] excuse my friends about the actual
properties at hand he cares how much
money they make he cares how uh much
they're worth but he does not care about
the actual projects at hand and you can
you can tell and I think that's the
biggest issue he's the guy that greenlit
face for of Marvel not Bob chapek Bob J
pick just happened to be there as it
started like because this is something
yeah chapex their scapegoat and I think
iger's really to blame for a lot of this
I still respect the man a lot uh I I
just I just wish he loved the medium he
chose to be an executive for that's all
uh but but yeah he's the top person
though and these sort of things needs to
be a businessman and they need to be
ruthless Jennifer salkey top of Amazon
some people have turned against her
recently saying look all the look at
these terrible projects she's done and
we we were talking yesterday with me on
your Channel about you know Amazon
seemed to be trying to grow up they seem
to be trying to reign in some of the
spending and be a bit more sensible they
were they've been
throwing money at things and then now
they're actually trying to be a grown-up
Studio yeah right
um but Jennifer stalking used to be a
business lady and one person I I in this
video I watched with the cop cast guys
they were saying well look at look at um
Citadel and I would actually argue at
the time I actually said yes sitting I
probably did bomb I think it it didn't
do well for how much it cost but
actually it did it did well enough and
I've only watched half the series and I
got bored of it after him and I stopped
watching me so I was like I failed I
didn't even question it but actually
looking at it it's just been um renewed
for a second series then apparently
around the world it did very well it
just didn't do great in America yeah
um so they've renewed it for second
serious but but Jennifer salkey from a
business point of view it's got the
Russo Brothers have come into my office
and they've got a project and they just
did all that great stuff at Marvel
here's 250 million quid crack on that's
in the Green Man decision
yeah and it's a sensible business
decision
uh it's what I would do if Russo
Brothers turned up and said we want to
make something for Amazon I'd be like
yeah yes please
I I would have been a little more
hesitant uh just because everything
they've done since gray man's been their
most successful Venture but extraction
one and two have been there's not
there's not really a way to gauge how uh
extraction one I I get wasn't great
extraction two is a brilliant movie and
apparently I I like it a lot uh and I'm
not saying the top of Netflix movie
stream for a good few weeks after they
were released but like like Netflix's
biggest problem is we don't have any of
that actual beta we don't know what
those numbers actually are so there's no
way to actually gauge how truly
successful those things are so I don't
think that helps in their case really uh
they also did Cherry with Tom Holland
which wasn't very successful they did 21
Bridges with Chadwick Boseman before he
passed away and that was not very good
not well received critical emergency it
did quite well but no it wasn't very
good film they basically had a
popularity off the back of black panther
didn't it yeah yeah and it really it did
well enough it didn't do like super well
it didn't do well enough for them to get
a big old budget for the Citadel I don't
think because that's closer to the type
of medium that they were going for than
what they did with Marvel so I I I don't
I don't necessarily think that
that budget makes sense and and you know
that's kind of the whole film industry
right now it's we've talked about this a
lot with fast X Transformers and another
slew of movies that have just come out
over over flash Indiana Jones
ain't a reign in these budgets and I I
think selki is going to be one of the
people that starts to do that uh heavily
which which is good for the company they
need to have business people in charge
but that business person needs to love
what they're doing as well I mean
because I couldn't argue with the
Citadel think that a proper business
person yes green let it but then kept an
eye on it exactly yeah it does seem
Amazon trust the creators which is a
good thing but people have actually
argued the rings of power problem was
that they hired a bunch of people who
didn't know what they were doing
and they basically learned on the job
yeah um and they've come out since this
first season ago we learned so much
we're going to change this we're going
to do this in the second season we're
going to make a bit more interesting
we're gonna make more exciting and blah
blah blah
um and I'm just like yeah that's too
much money to be learning on the job
with it
you know
but I like that they trust the creators
is the is the point but maybe they need
to do that a little bit less actually I
think there is a happy balance because
Batman the first Batman movie with
Michael Keaton right was made
um by the Tim Burton who I have a bit of
a love-hate relationship with so um I
love some stuff he's doing and I hate
others I actually think it's the perfect
example though of the good and badder
Tim Burton that the first Batman movie
Tim Burton wasn't massively famous he
done Edwards as his hands and that was
about it and he was watched by the
executives and producers
um and producers got involved and we got
an amazing batman movie with a bit of
Tim Burton
the second movie because it was the most
popular movie ever made at that point
they trusted Tim and Tim Burton made
Batman two all returns was it Batman
Returns and it is not as good it is a
big chunk of Tim Burton and a more
modern
example of that
Thor Ragnarok
is that kind of like perfect medium most
of the time uh phase one phase two just
MCU it felt like his hand was maybe a
little too heavy on a lot of things but
then you get into 2014 through 2019 and
that's just he trusted people invited
new people in he invited the Russo
brothers from Community to do Winter
Soldier in Civil War two of the biggest
things possible and those are two of the
greatest comic book movies I think we've
ever gotten Winter Soldier might still
be my favorite Marvel film uh we got
Guardians of the Galaxy that same year
because he decided hey let me trust
James Gunn this guy that makes quirky
little independent superhero movies or
quirky independent horror movies let's
see what he does and then taka YTD two
years later with Thor Ragnarok excellent
and and so on foreign
Drew him in stopped him going nuts but
then he was trusted so they went taika
brilliant job your Genius go for it and
we got love and Thunder
which is
balls deep Taiko ititi excuse my French
but new thing
um and
it's it's a it's a bad film because of
it I think taka watiti Tim Burton and
others that there's some of those
directors they need a team around them
they need to be told no sometimes
and you know something and it's not good
when they don't they're too creative
they're too much they're too this you
know they go they go overboard let's do
this let's do that okay they overexcited
and they and then they lose
the vision of you know what they're
trying to do well that's something that
I've I felt been wrong with Hollywood
for a long time is that people are
either and and
part of it I don't we're not going to
get political at all but you know people
either
tend to tend to fully focus on one thing
or not focus and not focus on another
and say oh this is my part of my craft I
think filmmaking needs to be a lot more
economical in in Hollywood I think from
The Writer's room up to the actual like
Studio Executives uh there's because the
only people that actually care about the
economics of the film tend to be the the
you're you're big producers that are
doing the bad things or your directors
yeah your big Studio execs screw all of
that the writers need to be economical
like hey we need to this is how we want
to shoot it or this is how we want to
present this to somebody to shoot it if
if we know we're going to shoot it in uh
in the medium like Mandalorian shoots
like all these Star Wars projects or
something like that then let's write the
series for something that fits that
instead of trying to make it so huge and
grandiose or something like that or
let's let's let's let's do what's
necessary
per the script per the narrative uh it
just
it's gotten so uneconomical in the sense
like the The Writer's room is
so far away from the executives like
they they to to talk to the person
actually funding your film that you're
writing you might have to talk to about
10 12 15 people before you can actually
get to that person sometimes yeah that
ain't right you should all be on the
same thing
mm-hmm I mean I've I've become aware of
that talking to certain sources that
I've got to that work at MGM and what
have you and they were saying that
um the one company they work for a
marketing company and they're saying
they've had multiple meetings they've
had a couple of meetings over Stargate
and things like this as well saying they
they ask for their advice and Star Trek
they ask for their advice on how should
we do this how should we present this
what would the people how would people
react to this and the person I speak to
regularly they're saying you never see
the same person twice you never see this
there's always it's a different
executive in charge of something else
and you never see the same person twice
and that you know sometimes you're like
oh can I actually just speak to somebody
that's in charge yeah you know it's just
like and they never know who that is
there's not a continuous conversation it
it's just a pick up pick up pick a
pickup and then you have all these
different puzzle pieces and that's how
you make a film where it's just I I
think you need to have that full outline
from the get go and not just the outline
of the script and and what you want to
look like on set where what not have
your shot list like prepared and all
that you need all that but it needs to
have a uh a coherence from The Writer's
room to the the funding to the financing
drag this back to school Star Wars
before we go because I've got to go and
cook tea for my children the ungrateful
little Suds they won't even thankfully
damage
um but
um I have to go do it so
Brad Wright when he wrote the first star
game will drag this back to Target
because it's behind me
um
basically the first time Amazon
apparently were raising concerns about
Brad Wright's script
excuse me because the rumor is
Amazon were always going to be the
customer
for the new Stargate franchise
when MGM was still MGM
they were the ones that approached them
said look we would love a Stargate
series and we will be the customer and
that's why they then went to Brad and
said we would love you to produce a
script
apparently during the
um then development stage that
information was then being shared back
with Amazon is the potential customers
secretly because they weren't supposed
nobody was supposed to know that they
were going to be the potential customer
and because they were thinking about
bidding so there was a bit of you know
rgbaji going up but anyway
so
Brad they kept being apparently Amazon
were telling MGM go big go bigger
um it's it's too it's too conformed it's
too you know it's too limited we want
bigger we want Grand and that was there
always their biggest complaint with Brad
Wright's idea for how to kick start the
franchise I think Brad Wright was
thinking MGM what's doable and Amazon
were thinking
tentpole franchise we want big
now Amazon are probably looking back and
thinking you know what Brad write script
wasn't that bad let's maybe have a think
about that because they seem to have
gone from three years ago
250 million dollars half a billion
dollars whatever on a project and now
all of a sudden they're thinking now we
need to be spending
less than 10 million dollars an episode
you know a series cannot cost 250
million dollars anymore
it's got you know our big projects need
to be 100 million dollars and no more
than that you know
um and if that's the true
then Kerry's got the point there
go and sign the petition there should be
a link in the description but the
present I'll add it later
um I haven't looked for a while but
we're running about just under 4 000
names for that so um we need to push
under that again because now you know we
were looking at things once this is
announced Brad right can't be involved
now it looks like this might not go nice
for months
ah I haven't been
I have a fear now
when he told me it's a green slate
and that
this is don't don't put money on
anything
don't say what you I'm worried about
what you're about to say and don't put
it out there no he's not he did not say
this to me but I think this is what he
was implying
Stargate is going to be an expensive
project
it is
yes I'm Amazon and I'm thinking we've
got to cut
spending we've got to do blah blah blah
do you look at Stargate and think
not just yet
oh no oh okay that went completely I
thought you were going to say I don't
even want to say the words
yeah I don't even want to put that I
thought that's where we were going I was
like no no no no no no no no no no I was
gonna I was gonna come back to the hard
reboot options
that's worse than Voldemort right there
that's uh I I would rather hard reboot
than nothing
but like we were discussing yesterday I
think Stargate has the potential to be
worth more than James Bond for Amazon uh
just just with the array of things they
have and and the capability of of a fan
base already baked in and built in that
large they they could do a lot with it
so I don't think it's something that
they're gonna let sit
um
I I yeah I just don't think it's
something that did lets it simply put uh
if they're if they do kind of course
correct and change courses
hey that Brad ride script it's waiting
it's waiting but I think they'd go with
something cheaper instead of going with
something huge but that that could also
push us into
um you're gonna have to remind me his
name the guy that runs MGM plus because
he wants the cheapest Target over there
um
that was something I said on your video
yesterday that there will be clips from
appearing on our channel to Frank at you
oh and more customers
um but I I did hear and this is firmly
in the rumor category and I don't even
want to I don't know anyone say to me
rumor
but apparently somebody I spoke to some
spoke to somebody else this is why
you've got to take it with a massive
grain of salt I mean I would take a
handful of salt and throw it over your
shoulder but apparently Steve Wright
came back from a meeting
um with Jennifer sulky uh about two
weeks ago and came in yelled at somebody
because they were in his way and then
kicked a bin across the room
and the Rumor was that that meeting was
about Target
and something else there was another
project as well that was being talked
about but mainly it was about Stargate
Mike Wright death Minecraft Steve right
oh it's getting mixed up because they
were saying um there's a radio presenter
over here called Mike right I think
Steve Wright but um he
um desperately wants Stargate for MGM
plus because he's in charge of MGM plus
that's his thing he wants that channel
to do well and he knows Stargate on MGM
plus would be good for MGM plus you
can't argue with his thinking I don't
care if they put an MGM Plus in America
and put it on Prime the rest of the
world I'd be fine with that because I
live in the rest of the world but um you
know I it's just
is the largest Stargate audience still
in the US though or is it
I care about me being able to watch it
yeah no I'm just thinking of an
executive's mindset you know
um he's just thinking that would be a
massive draw to MGM plus that I mean if
they get Stargate everyone's going to be
talking about MGM Plus for six months
yeah it'd be huge for them it'd be their
way biggest thing no they did Billy the
Kid good show actually I have seen it
um but nobody's talking about it
you know it's um it's not really doing
anything for the channel they need
something people are going to talk about
so then when Michael Wright gets told
it's not going to MGM plus which is I
imagine what the conversation how the
Manchester in my opinion I'm spitballing
but you know I can imagine that he came
back and kicked him in across the room
because he's thinking MGM plus is my
thing I'm in charge of this and I'm not
gonna can get it
I did also wonder though apparent I did
wonder was freebie was he told actually
that Stargate was going off really
because that would have annoyed me if I
was in
there already on freebie we got an
announcement about a week after that
that um stargate's gonna be hearing us
freebie it's not at the moment it was I
don't think it is yeah it's not here
anyway I haven't checked with you guys
but um we got an announcement about a
week after that that yeah they're
getting a Freeview channel for a few
Phoebe channels for Stargate so that's
right
anyway
let's just get it done already damn it
too many false starts too many come on
things you know we got this news about
Amanda Tapping potentially saying that
thing and then we can turn that not to
be true
just gonna throw this past you because
I'm going into conspiracy theory here
there's lessons shared by a couple of
people and I'm not going to say I
believe this
but
rumor yeah rumor has it
um
basically they came out I did a video
about that and I believe I'm the only
person that put the video out but it did
get
people talking about it that Amanda
Tappan had said that she was as she'd
been approached
about doing this thing it turns out the
the source that the the the very nice
subscriber that saw just mishaired I
think apparently it's a joke she says
sometimes and I think the subscriber
just misunderstood that it was a joke
told me and I put it out there for good
faith because I've been told repeatedly
that Amanda Tapping has been approached
if Amanda Tapping though has been
approached
and she's signed an NDA
right and then some idiot accidentally
says that she told people in a big room
full of thousands of people that she'd
been approached
would that maybe explain why her and the
and the Comic-Con involved very quickly
released a statement saying that it
wasn't true
am I just my own two and two and M6
there or am I thinking that that maybe
makes sense
no I can't make sense
ignore this stupid little Sidetrack
channel that has said that she said that
and I would ignore it and but they
obviously chose not to because
you know they they felt they had to and
I'm just wondering hey conspiracy theory
I used to do a conspiracy channel to
shoot me
well that makes me think also conspiracy
still uh a rumor has it down here uh
not not really uh but I if if you know
you know people like you know I I was
watching beef uh I have one episode left
of beef and and one of my favorite
little lines is uh
oh I don't remember who says it is is
one of the main two characters it's
either Ali Wong or Steven Young's
character and they uh they say
exactly what they've done they're like
oh yeah we I'm doing this road rage I've
done this this this this this and this
and then it's like it's they say it
sarcastically though so nobody in the
room believes them and you know we all
know people that have done that a
thousand times oh yeah I backed into
your car out out front and you're like
big dent you're like no no you didn't it
was like oh no I didn't you go back out
there there's a freaking dent in your
car you're like oh great you know uh but
it's someone saying something that is
true but in a sarcastic way so then it
kind of takes you off of their Trail a
little bit
that may be a little bit of what's
happening I guess but that's that's just
complete speculation of course uh but I
know that's that's that's what I do if
I'm in that kind of situation and I'm
like oh yeah I didn't smoke those two
joints and and walk and wander this way
to and and I'm supposed to be giving
like a speech right now or something not
at all and then you know right after I
started having a conversation with
people they're like your eyes are red as
hell I'm like
[Music]
I really need some food some Pringles or
something but yeah I I just want to add
that thing hey that's it it's a
possibility like as far as I'm saying I
removed the video because the video is
false it's it's incorrect she did not
say that
but to be honest it now makes me more
convinced that it's actually true in a
way because the way they reacted to it
to the way it was the reaction to it
makes you think like but that's maybe
just my my um cynical mind
that actually says it's true so we'll
see what let's do it I'm I'm just
waiting I'm just patiently not not so
patiently waiting I'm trying to
patiently wait hey we're gonna keep
talking about it we're going to keep
having some fun with it we're gonna keep
you know I've been doing this silliness
I got doing the health and safety Guy
video and I need to think of how to do
it but um but you know it's
um
we'll keep talking because people want
to listen and if you don't want to
listen to it
go away don't comment
don't bring me long essays about why I'm
an evil person I shouldn't be making
money off a channel talking about
something I love but if you do they need
to be at least four paragraph double
space MMA format and
it should be signed cordially of course
yes obviously of course with maximum
respect you lying bastard which is one
thing I did get called
um
I just I have to laugh about it it just
makes me giggle now this is pretty funny
nothing you have ever said has been
right so I listed stuff I've said this
right and like yeah but other than that
other than that
do you like that it's 70 of it like
yeah in fact and and the other stuff is
just not been released but anyway yeah
exactly
twice I've got stuff wrong twice damn it
in two years that that that's the best
track record maybe out of yeah
a source making a genuine mistake an
honest genuine mistake the first one
I've told you about the bread right
whenever and I oh God that killed me
when Brad Wright actually texted me to
go that's not true
um yeah so we did a guy there's a bunch
of meetings about my MGM and then the
security guard I can say it was just
security guard now because he stopped
talking to me after it said I've just
seen him theories in the building so I
went he's there he's talking he's at MGM
and Brad Wright himself went no I'm not
it's just another dude with white hair
walking into the hallway right he's
wearing a damn mask
this is like did you decide did you just
say a big guy with gray hair walk
through this and he was just like I
thought it was Brad
did you look up a picture of Brad right
first like yeah
um it's just yeah two times wrong on a
room a channel I'm doing okay
when I talk about rumors and stuff so
I'm doing okay anyway not that some
people see that but I don't really give
[__]
um I used to really care though I'll
tell you what I used I was talking to a
guy off um uh the shuttle pod
um so this goes it's actually live the
video's Gone live I thought it was
tomorrow
um so if you can get off here go
straight watch that interview it's an
hour long but it's oh he's brilliant
he's so funny half an hour it's
excellent y'all yeah so um you have to
address I had to edit it down a little
bit now except I did realize I've not
edited it at one point he goes up and
get some stuff for drinking just I mean
you can see me watching my phone and
editing it out
um so
so yeah um what was I say but but yeah
he was talking about that and the the
crap they get and they just have they're
not a controversial Channel they're not
seeing anything controversial really
they just talk like friends and they're
saying they get loads of [__] and I was
like well I'm glad it's not just me
well they did get a little controversial
with David blue talking about the the
the SGU SGA stuff and then Flanagan
coming in with the other end of the the
Spectrum there not truly controversial
it's just good to see them
the stuff they got crap over was um they
were chatting about guns
[Music]
oh yeah he's got guns in his kids got a
gun and the closest group of guns
um but they're they're trying to be
responsible gun owners right side of it
um no wanting range is fully loaded none
of that monster of course not in the
middle issue or anything
um but they got they got crap from both
sides because the the good nuts will go
and you weren't
you know you weren't thinking if you
should have been like you should have
put your guns on with you or something
um clean the weapon on on air that's
what they went nuts but then the others
obviously the other side of the argument
they went nuts and you're promoting good
crime you you kill babies
um and they're just like and they're
just like we couldn't we were just
chatting
and but the one funny thing in the video
is go and listen to the bit where he
talks about the avocado tree it's
hilarious it's so funny from your video
or he talks about it on my video yeah um
but they've got an avocado tree
and that has caused a lot of controversy
I personally would mock them for owning
an avocado tree oh there's an avocado
tree four feet away from me right now
and I'm about to make the best damn
guacamole you might ever see in your
life today so avocado trees are amazing
you uh and you've well you've you've
lowered your expectations I'm just I'm
just thinking oh my god
um but I'm British we didn't even know
that avocado was until about like five
years ago
good point
um so we were just like
what and if you avocado you'll have
probably doesn't get that good at flavor
you know you all get like the mild
guacamoles if you get anything yeah we
get a little bit of spicy guacamole but
not much not much no but we don't get
fresh guacamole all that much I know
what guacamole was I didn't know what it
came from until I was about 30 years old
I was like of course on this little
green thing what the hell and then my
girlfriend at the time really decided
she likes guacamole
and I started to like do avocado on
toast and I I would make a friend like
what is this slimy green crap and she
was like you like guacamole so you like
avocados and I was like I like guacamole
what the hell has that got to do with
avocados
it's like it's because that's what it's
made out of oh okay oh that makes sense
yeah that's like I took a girl on a date
once though and
um I decided to be a vegetarian once
when I was a little boy so my dad had
just spent a lot of money on some Gammon
so he told me it was a fish
and I'm like I'm not eating this fish
this Gammon thinking yum this this is
the nicest fish and I know it's meaty
but I thought it was like tuna or
something it was like a meaty fish
um but then my dad never told me he'd
lied to me so years later I took this
girl out on a date
and we're at a meal and she went I'm a
vegetarian but I do eat fish and I'm
like oh don't worry then darling I'll
order you the cabin so and she was like
why
weirdly that girl still went over for me
that was me for like a year
that reminds me of uh My Big Fat Greek
Wedding when when the mom's like the the
I think the whoever says oh I'm a
vegetarian and the mom's like Oh we'll
give you lamb
it's like the ultimate non-vegetarian so
not just meat baby meat but of course
it's so good
right guacamole avocados are disgusting
oh I need to make y'all some guacamole
I'm gonna make y'all some guacamole and
next year sir you have a Comic Con and
it's good
make us some guacamole
I'm cooking with Harris it's gonna be
great up smoking weed for [__] you have
to get baked prior to baking or you got
yeah
right guys thank you so much everybody
in the um and that's that's been
listening in the comments you are
absolute Legends thank you so much the
the couple of guys that contributed to
the channel as well you are legends
thank you so much it really helps us it
lets us it's just you see baby it really
helps us to do more content and you know
my wife lets me because
I pay for stuff now off the channel
YouTube
and it helps me to you know
help others as well so you know we do
get to give a nice little bit of money
to charity that guy was having a go at
me and having to go with me for how much
money I went I told them how much money
I've given to charity in the last 18
months and reading weirdly he didn't
mention money again after that
speaking of Charities uh Jay has
mentioned he will give a little bit uh
if if you can get somebody from Stargate
or anybody cool send it our way and and
he'll donate to a little Charity uh a a
small website 30 billion quid I'm
kidding um yeah I don't have 30 billion
quid unless it's in like Yen or
something I can do it in the end okay
um but I will again I will give that one
so yeah I I mean I just think like this
is a hobby for me I need to earn a
little bit of money off it so I can
actually do it
and my wife let me but the fact that we
can
give a little bit of help to these
little Charities and things I think it's
amazing absolutely love it and it makes
it worth it more so than just the fun
hobby aspect of it it adds another level
to it it's just it's rewarding it's cool
and um I never mentioned it for like 18
months because I felt like a bit of a
dick and I just thought you know what no
bollocks do it because it's not me
really this dude it's you guys you guys
come on here and you watch our stupid
little Channel and you know you make
donations like that and it allows us to
do something that amazing
um and I'm thinking oh actually you want
bollocks do I'm going to check it from
the rooftops I'm proud of it I'm really
proud that we get to do that
um
so it's amazing yeah love it right thank
you so much Harris for jumping on at
last minute as well because I only
decided to do it 30 minutes before we
went live but thank you so much everyone
chat like I said we will catch you
Sunday man I'm certain we will probably
be discussing a few of these topics
again
thank you so much gentlemen let me just
find the outro and then we'll see you
next week see you Sunday
good
foreign
[Music]